this is the second time I've replied to
a conservative Prime Minister seeking to
dissolve Parliament to call an election
because they didn't have a deliverable
brexit policy although I'm not
condemning the right honourable member
for bait Maidenhead by comparing her to
a successor she at least made detailed
speeches setting out her brexit policy
even if we fundamentally disagreed with
them this Prime Minister claims he has a
strategy but he can't tell us what it is
the bigger problem for him is that he
hasn't told the EU what it is either
and if Prime Minister's question time
today as with the statement yesterday he
was unable to say whether he's even made
any proposals whatsoever to the EU and
it's basically a policy that's cloaked
in mystery like the Emperor's New
Clothes there really is absolutely
nothing there and the naked truth is
that the reality is deeply unpalatable a
disastrous no deal brexit to take us
into the arms of a trade deal with
Donald Trump that will run America first
and Britain a distant second
the Prime Minister knows there is no
mandate for No Deal no majority support
for in the country and no majority for
it in this house the Chancellor of the
Duchy of Lancaster the co convener of
the vote leave campaign said in March
this year we didn't vote to leave
without a deal even the leaders even the
leaders
[Applause]
leaders of the leave campaign are
absolutely clear that the referendum
confirmed no mandate for No Deal No Deal
No Deal
No Deal is opposed by every business
group every industry body every trade
union and by this house as today's folks
and others have shown
mr. speaker we wanted elections we look
for the turfing this coming down
and
[Applause]